- Let's give it up for
Daughtry's lead singer,
Chris Daughtry!
(rock music playing)
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
Hey, what's up, man?
Your beard game is on point.
(Chris laughs)
- Thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Oh, my God.
You guys are having
way too much fun there.
I wish I was there.
- I know, I might've had too much macha.
I know I have a lot of caffeine.
(laughing)
So something's happening.
- I got my coffee here.
It's my drug of choice these days.
- It's my lifeline.
I love it.
How have you been?
- Yeah.
I'm awesome.
Honestly, like, life is so good.
I miss being on the road,
but, I'm also really
loving this home life.
I haven't been home this long
in 15 years, so, it's cool.
I get to be on your show and
at home at the same time.
- I know, it's like, says every musician
in the world for the last year and a half.
Like every, everybody just
was like, "Wait, what?
What do we do?"
Like, 'cause we're all
used to going and going.
- Yeah, it takes some getting used to.
- Yeah, agreed.
Well, your new song is
called "Heavy Is The Crown."
So, what's it about?
- You know, I think, I was
thinking about it today.
I was like, "We're all kind of, like,
the stars of our own movie."
You know what I mean?
Like, we're all are, are all
the leads in our own film
and we're, we are the kings
and queens of our own castle.
And life has so much, like,
there's so much pressure on
just to live, especially these days.
And, not only that, but the pressures of
carving your own path
without conforming to what
everyone else thinks is normal.
And...
Yeah, just the daily choices
that we have to make.
It's a lot of pressure sometimes.
And, I guess you can
kinda sum it up that way.
- Yeah, I mean, God, that was nicely done.
I feel a little sad, but that's okay.
Performing...
(laughing)
'Cause I love the message.
I love that it's deep.
And I think a lot of people relate
especially for this past year and a half.
Everybody, you know, heavy is a crown.
You feel, if you're
responsible for your family,
if your responsible for...
There's, you know, a lot
going on, financial crisis,
mental health is an issue right now,
people have lost their jobs.
Like, it's a lot going on.
So, it's, you know, probably
good to have a song that,
you know, comes out and people relate to.